- [Narrator] How great people think.
On April 16, 2000,
the New England Patriots
drafted an extra quarterback
out of Michigan State.
They had scouted him thoroughly
and had their eye on him for sometime.
Seeing that he was still
available, they took him.
It was the sixth round and
the 199th pick of the draft.
The young quarterback's
name was Tom Brady.
He was fourth string at the
beginning of his rookie season.
By his second season, he was a starter.
New England won the Super Bowl that year.
Brady was named MVP.
In terms of return on investment,
it's probably the single
greatest draft pick
in the history of football.
Four Super Bowl rings
out of six appearances,
13 starting seasons, 160 wins,
392 touchdowns, three Super Bowl MVPs,
53,000 yards, 10 pro balls,
and more division titles than
any quarterback in history.
It's not even finished paying dividends.
Brady may still have many
more seasons left in him.
So you'd think the Patriots' front office
would be ecstatic with how it turned out
and indeed they were.
They were also disappointed,
deeply so in themselves.
Brady's surprising abilities
meant that the Patriots'
scouting reports were way off
for all their evaluations of players.
They had somehow missed or miscalculated
all of his intangible attributes.
They had let this gem wait
until the sixth round.
Someone else could have drafted him.
More than that,
they didn't even know they
were right about Brady
until injuries knocked out Drew Bledsoe,
their prized starter,
and forced them to realize his potential.
So even though their bet paid off,
the Patriots honed in on the
specific intelligence failure
that could have prevented
the pick from happening
in the first place.
Not that they were nitpicking
or indulging in perfectionism,
they had higher standards
of performance to adhere to.
For years, Scott Pioli,
Director of Personnel for the Patriots,
kept the photo on his
desk of Dave Stachelski,
a player the team had
drafted in the fifth round
but who never made it
through training camp.
It was a reminder,
you're not as good as you think.
You don't have it all figured out.
Stay focused.
Do better.
Bo Jackson wouldn't get
impressed when he hit a home run
or ran a touchdown
because he knew he
hadn't done it perfectly.
In fact, he didn't ask for the ball
after his first hit in
Major League Baseball
for that reason.
To him, it was just a
ground ball up the middle.
This is a characteristic
of how great people think.
It's not that they find
failure in every success.
They just hold themselves
to a standard that exceeds
what society might consider
to be objective success.
Because of that,
they don't much care
what other people think.
They care whether they
meet their own standards
and these standards are much, much higher
than everyone else's.
The Patriots saw the Brady pick
as being more lucky than smart
and although some people are fine
giving themselves credit for luck,
they weren't.
In this instance,
instead of celebrating or
congratulating themselves,
they put their heads back down
and focus on how to get even better.
This isn't necessarily fun by the way.
It can feel like self-inflicted
torture sometimes,
but it does force you to always keep going
and always improve.
For us, the scoreboard can't
be the only scoreboard.
Warren Buffett has said the same thing.
Making the distinction
between the inner scorecard
and the external one,
your potential, the absolute
best you're capable of,
that's the metric to
measure yourself against,
your standards are.
Winning is not enough.
Anyone can win,
but not everyone can be
the best they can be.
Think of the times that you've
excused your own behavior
with no one will know.
Because it's not about
what you can get away with,
it's about what you
should or shouldn't do.
A person who judges themselves
based on his own standards
doesn't crave the spotlight
the same way as someone who
lets applause dictate success.
A person who can think longterm
doesn't pity herself during
her short-term setbacks.
A person who values the
team can share credit
and subsume his own interest
in a way that most others can't.
Reflecting on what went
well or how amazing we are
doesn't get us anywhere
except maybe to where we are right now,
but we want to go further.
We want more.
We want to continue to improve.
This is a characteristic
of how great people think.